as many of you know being a Creator is
more to me than just making content you
guys see me in other comment sections at
events I'm all about that Creator what
that's why I was really excited when
YouTube's reached out about doing a cz's
world vinyl figure because I had seen my
favorite creators release YouTube's
figures over the years so to me this was
more than just a cool merchandise
opportunity this was a rite of passage I
wanted to make my YouTube's the greatest
one of all time so I did this easiest
World YouTubes combines my classic
Horror history getup complete with
Overlook Hotel carpet pattern tie with
the iconic cz's World logo mask we
really went all in on the details for
this not just on the figure itself but
the entire box and presentation is
premium artwork and because of that it's
only going to be available for a very
limited time once these are gone they're
gone forever unless you want to be
shelling out millions of dollars to get
one of these on eBay in the future I'd
recommend you pick it up now by clicking
that link in the description I'm super
excited to announce that these are now
available and I'm looking forward to
seeing what the cz's world Community
does with their YouTube so make sure and
send me those pictures on social media
once you receive them you too can take
home a piece of cz's world with you
two's